you mentioned your interest your
admiration of Albert Camus of stoicism
perhaps your interest in existentialism
Camus said
I believe in myth of Sisyphus the only
way to deal with an unfree world is to
become so absolutely free that your very
existence is an act of rebellion what do
you think he means by that I suppose
viewed the world
um and the way that the stoics did and a
lot of the existentialists was that it
was uh that it was so absurd and that
the uh the the problems and the tasks
that were given just to live a life are
so insurmountable that the only way that
we can kind of um get back the gods for
giving us this you know this uh this uh
impossible task of living life
I was to embrace it and to enjoy it and
to do our our best at it I mean to me I
you know I read camo and then
particularly in the myth of Sisyphus as
a
um as kind of as a parable that uh and
it's the same lesson that I think he
right he writes about in the plague
we're we're all given these
insurmountable tasks in our lives but
um that uh by doing our duty by being of
service to others
we can bring meaning to a meaningless
chaos and we can bring an order to the
universe and
you know Sisyphus was uh was kind of the
uh iconic hero of the stoics
and he was a man because he did uh
because he did something good he
delivered a gift to humanity
he angered the gods and they condemned
him to put a rock up the hill every day
and then it would roll down when he got
to the top it would roll down and he'd
spend the night going back down the hill
to collect it and then rolling it back
up the hill again
and the task was observed it was
insurmountable he could never win
but the last line of that book is one of
the great lines which is uh which is
something to the extent that you know I
can picture Earth says smiling because
Camus belief was that even though he um
his task was insurmountable that he was
a happy man
and he was a happy man because he put
his shoulder to the stone
he took his duty he embraced the test
and the you know and
the absurdity of life and he pushed the
stone up the hill and that if we do that
and if you know we find ways of being of
service to others that is you know the
ultimate
that's the key to the lock that's the
solution to the puzzle each individual
person in that way can rebel against
absurdity by discovering meaning to this
whole messy thing and we can bring
meaning not only to our own lives but
we can bring meaning to the universe as
well we can bring some kind of order to
life
um and uh you know that those the
Embrace of those tasks and the and the
commitment to service
resonates out from us to the rest of
humanity in some in some way